♪ (instrumental music) ♪
ListView and GridView are perfect
if you want to scroll through a list
or a grid of items separately.
But what if you want to list
and grid this scroll together
or create some other complex
scrolling effect?
That's what SliverList
and SliverGrid are for!
A Sliver is just a portion
of a scrollable area
and goes inside a custom scroll view.
Because Slivers can lazily build each item
just as it scrolls into view,
Slivers are particularly useful
for efficiently scrolling through
large numbers of children.
SliverList takes a delegate parameter,
which provides the items in the list
as they scroll into view.
You can specify the actual list of children
with a SliverChildListDelegate.
Or build them lazily
with a SliverChildBuilderDelegate.
SliverGrids also can specify
children with a delegate,
or an explicit list.
But there's some additional formatting
for the crossAxis dimension on a grid.
Use the count constructor
to specify how many items
across the grid it should contain.
Or specify the maximum width of items
to determine how many
you should fit across a grid
with the extent constructor.
For more info on SliverList, SliverGrid
and all the other Flutter widgets,
head over to flutter.io